hi everyone i'm i'm super excited to be
here thank you my friend thanks so much
for inviting me also this is the second
in person talk i've given since march
2000
2020 right march 2020 i gave a talk at
berkeley uh march 9th and they closed
that day
so they closed i think they sent out the
announcement around noon my talk was at
four so that was awesome
and ever since you know uh life has been
odd
so i hope you're all doing well i hope
you all are were able to kind of
uh
navigate those conditions in the best
optimal way for you guys uh but just
kind of as a i'm starting all my talks
virtual or in person just acknowledging
the fact that it's been a rough two
years
and
it's gonna be okay
we're all gonna
it's gonna be okay we're gonna ramp up
again some of you have never ramped down
but uh
um yes
okay uh the other thing i want to say is
that um i would much prefer an
interactive talk so stop me at any point
happy i do not have to go through all my
slides i was just telling anthony i have
26 slides
which is if i don't know if you've given
like hour or 45 minute talks uh
typically people have
more
than that so we'll see how that goes
um and yeah and i would much prefer kind
of interaction interactive conversation
the third thing i wanted to say is that
i've been giving typically i give talks
to kind of in a robotic setting so
robotic seminars or you know department
seminars or something like that and what
i really liked about this specific
seminar is the topic of it which is uh
ai and safety i kind of want to look at
the word safety a little bit more so i'm
going to talk it's going to be slightly
i don't know if philosophical is the
right word but there's one thing i want
you to take out from this of this talk
and we'll get to that
okay
so questions
yes interactions yes staring me for an
hour and not uh interacting with me at
all
not so much
all right so safety and liveness of
robot behaviors so i think i'm the first
you've had a uh talk this semester on
self-driving cars i think i'm the first
robotics type uh
uh seminar here so of course i have to
start with a bunch of videos of
robots failing
so this is the first one video i want to
show so this this is a compilation that
i spectrum did
this is the darpa robotics challenge
this happened in 2015.
it was a challenge that was kind of
inspired by the fukushima daiichi
disaster
so the idea was um have robots perform
eight tasks that have to do with with uh
um disaster scenarios
and this is the compilation of the first
day of the finals the finals were two
days i was involved in one of the teams
uh of all the failures
right so what are you seeing here you're
you're seeing a whole bunch of
robots falling
robots falling
actually ihms did it really well so this
is the first day they didn't ah but then
they did really really well
um a bunch of you know sensors not
giving the right quite the right
information
uh
you know these are humanoids they really
wanted humanoids not all of them were
humanoids but they really wanted this
one i wanted to take a look at because
this is interesting
you see the valve next to it it was
supposed to hang onto the valve and turn
it
so this was a mismatch between what the
robot thought it was doing
because if it had it been holding onto
the valve it would have just turned and
be fine
but didn't quite realize that this is
the mit um
uh
example here which is kind of i really
like this example as well so this is um
for two reasons one reason is that um
they got the point there was a point of
getting out of the car sort of an egress
point getting out of the car into the
pavement and you had to be within the
square
robot isn't the square that got the
point
but the thing i like most about this and
this is kind of really a huge credit to
rust ted rayk and his group is that the
robot fell
broke its right arm
um most of the testing was done with the
right arm
because they had algorithms that were
fairly robust they continued the
competition with the left arm
and did very well so there were a few
tasks that needed both arms so they
couldn't do those but for that day the
first day they continued with the left
arm and were successful that's kind of a
kind of uh an interesting aspect here
another one i want to show you this is i
think you don't know what this is
okay
mit car
cornell car predates me so this is a uh
the darpa urban challenge so really the
the
i would say the event that started the
amazing industry that we see around us
in terms of self-diving cars
so uh this is during the finals
and what you'll see here i think i have
my volume on
[Applause]
okay
the promise is the only thing i'm doing
with the sound just because of the the
yay-o kind of reactions right so what
happened there cornell stopped they had
to reset mit was behind was passing it
because they thought it was a static
obstacle
uh cornell woke up and or you know the
finished restarting started moving
mit wasn't expecting that because he
thought it was a static obstacle and
there was a there was a collision uh you
know a tiny fender bender they both
completed the competition they were uh
both mit and cornell were and pen
because i wasn't pen at the time so
let's be a little bit proud there monroe
um
and uh uh so it wasn't a terrible
accident but it was kind of an
interesting
thing in the context of safety
the last video i want to show
is kind of this interesting this was hr
study
hr paper from 2015 this is a robot in a
mall
and it's uh i actually forget exactly
what the purpose of it was but you can
see
that it's not really able to do anything
because its environment
is not being particularly helpful
right
okay so the topic of the seminar is ai
safety
there's the notion the word safety
and i want to think about what does that
word safety me in the context of
embodied
system
in the context of robots
right or in general when i say when we
say the word safety what does that mean
all right so if for anything from from
those uh um
from those videos
a few things kind of
uh
that that resonate with me i don't know
with you
safety
think about that i think we were just
talking about what safety means right
safety a lot of times means don't
collide
yes definitely that it's definitely part
of safety
what does it also mean right does it
mean that it should be expected behavior
doesn't mean that the robot i mean the
robot can in the context of robotics
a stationary robot is super safe
right you need to run into it to have
something bad happen to you
so safety is not quite enough
we have to start thinking about things
that that kind of we think about in
terms of properties so we call liveness
the robot also needs to do something
there needs to be some goals
so it's not just safety it's safety and
liveness
now how that relates also to kind of
other um branches of ai
i don't know and i but but uh i
um
but i know i don't know and i don't know
if this is a conversation that's
happening in those in those circles in
terms of safety versus liveness
don't do something bad but do something
good kind of thing so that's kind of an
interesting uh kind of
thing that that
again for robotics it's kind of clear
you want the robot to do something
now what it should actually do that's a
different conversation
in robotics it's not just the robot
right it's the environment
and if i'm thinking i'm grasping
something but it's not there well it's
probably on the robot because the
perception didn't like didn't quite do
its thing but you know it wasn't there
i'm gonna fall the kids around me i
don't control them right are they going
to be in my way
so the robot can be super safe and not
move
but you know the kid can just come and
kick it can come and kick it i don't
know if it is in that paper but there's
definitely i have definitely seen
uh um
works in robotics specifically in human
robot interaction where the word kick
comes into play
i don't know more than that i don't know
uh maybe anymore
um
and finally safety also is not well
there are some global properties
so you know don't kill anyone it would
be a global property but there are some
things that are very context dependent
right robotics sometimes you want a
physical interaction there is
there are a bunch of groups that deal
with
physical human robot interaction assist
assistive devices
exoskeletons you know there's a bunch of
different um robots out there and an
autonomous robot in that that do have to
have some notion of touch
is that a collision no it's not a
collision is it too hard then it becomes
dangerous yes maybe
there's some things a car i don't really
don't want to touch anybody right so
there's kind of questions of contacts
and questions of what does safety mean
within that context
all right so um
that is kind of philosophically in terms
of uh
things that i think translate to
different domains but are specifically
important in robotics these notions of
uh what does safety mean
so what i'm going to argue uh i don't
know if argue is probably too strong of
a word what i'm going to advocate for
and this is not something that just my
group does but
i'm going to advocate for the fact that
we need
to be able to discuss specifications
we need to have specification formalisms
we need to be able to capture what it is
that constitutes safety
what it is that constitute liveness
right how do i even talk about these
things
so i can see a behavior me as it does i
can see a behavior and say um well that
doesn't quite look right
but why does it not look right
if it hits something well that's very
easy to say don't hit something
if it if it's reacting there's notions
of fluency for example especially with
the researchers in hri
the emotions of fluency that you want to
maintain
in an interaction
how do i capture that
i'll get back to that
so i'm going to uh with your permission
amend the the the
title of my talk to say specifications
safety and live messages
so i want to talk about specifications
and i want to talk about different types
of specifications
or i'm going to talk about a specific
kind of flavor of specifications there
are other things as well of course which
we can discuss
but i want to give you a taste of
um the types of specifications that
we've been looking at in my group and
other groups
as well
and what we can do with that and why
it's useful and why it's powerful the
idea of thinking about what what it is
that we want to do what is safety
what is liveness
all right so when i talk about
specifications
a few things that i want to have these
are a few properties of those
specifications
i want them to be somewhat abstract
i don't want to to uh the specification
to be an actual implementation of what
the robot does
right i don't want to write the program
because the robot because then i'm
losing this kind of ability to talk
about what it is that the robot should
be doing or you can replace the robot
with any system but i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go with robot
so it has to have a certain level of
abstraction a certain level being able
to generalize
it has to after capture some important
properties so safety and aliveness are
examples of properties it should be
um
holding
and you know um so kind of funny i'm an
electrical engineer by training as
you may have heard i'm i'm a faculty
member in mechanical aerospace
engineering
and a lot of things i do are kind of uh
um cs i'm giving you talking and this is
a cs
seminar right
so
the important thing about specifications
is that or
to make them particularly useful you
want them to be computable or what i
mean by that i want to make sure that
these specifications are amenable
to things like verification
synthesis
uh explanations
right and i'm emphasizing the synthesis
and explanation because that's kind of
more what i do we have some work on
verification which i'm not going to talk
about
and um just kind of in terms of
terminology um
when i think about verification i think
about i have a system
i have a specification
don't collide
and verification is the process of uh
proving
or exhaustively searching the space or
whatever proving that the system
satisfied the property synthesis is kind
of the opposite of that
i have a specification i have something
i want the system to do now now let me
create in a correct correct by
construction way
let me generate a system that does the
specification i also want to use these
specifications to be able to provide
explanations to tie back
behaviors of the system
to the requirements on those behaviors
so i have maybe i have a specification
and and and something bad happened i
want to say okay this part of the
specification
is violated
or this part of the specific
specification will soon be violated as
you'll see in a little bit
right
so um
anthony asked me about two yes
please so you talk about specifications
being abstract and isn't that kind of
isn't there any kind of trade-off
between how abstract the specification
should be versus the actual thing like
is the specification fully specifying
everything every behavior of the system
or is there a trade-off what if it is
supposed to fully specify everything is
there afraid of what happens
how should we go about it and that kind
of relates to the explanation yeah yeah
exactly exactly what i was going to say
it relates very much the explanation i
think that's a wonderful question i wish
i had a really good answer for you i
don't right
there's no way you can you can specify
everything that the system could do
right you need at some point
based on the context and based on the
properties that are important to you
make sure that the up that the
specification
formalism abstraction level how how
fine-grained it is matches that right so
um
yeah i mean that's that's an awesome
question but but with the baseline of we
can never specify everything
but we also don't want to be so
prescriptive that there's only one
behavior in the system because then
basically you're writing an
implementation so that's not interesting
either right so you want to say okay you
know i never want to collide
um
actually i'll show you an example i
think that maybe that but but i don't
i don't have a general rule of thumb in
terms of what is the right level of
abstraction that's kind of things we're
thinking about and and also
as you know the specification formulas
i'm going to i'm going to be talking
about uh they're not the only formalisms
we need to think about it so kind of
thinking about the combination between
things like reward functions or things
like that which are also a form of
specification as again i i i
um you're the person to talk about um
fits somewhere in there right reward
functions are a little bit
i'll get to that yeah
not here but i'll get to that
other questions
okay
so uh there were two papers that that
that their links on it for for the um
sheamus you know
shamelessly plugging my own papers but
you know it is what it is i i was asked
i'm gonna give give the papers
one of them is a review on um
synthesis for robots from the
perspective of temporal logic
so
in this paper um
we describe
different type well we talk about
synthesis from logical specifications
so this is by no means the only type of
specification formalisms we can think
about but that's what i'm going to talk
about today these different uh temporal
logics and i'm going to tell you what
temporal logics are um because i'm
guessing
actually i don't know i don't know how
many people who who has heard about
temporal logic like linear temporal
logic oh wow
okay
more than
it's definitely changed in the years
right so there's a lot more it was about
i don't know about half of the people
which which is
cool
very excited to see that so my apologies
you're going to see some a couple of
slides that might be totally boring for
you
so i want to talk about so this is one
paper in which we talk about we talk
about specifications we talked about
models we talk about algorithms to
synthesize systems from temporal logic
specifications
ltl stl um pctl different different
types of logics
so what i want to do now is i want to
show you a logic and show you what we
can do with it i'm going to give you a
couple of examples of things we've done
in my group
using these logics i'm going to do this
for ltl linear temporal logic i'm going
to do this for sdl single temporal logic
that's it
and then and then we'll continue
okay
i have i feel like this is a mandatory
slide in every type we give right so the
the ltl my ltl slide
uh it is it has the the right syntax and
semantics i typically don't talk you
know particularly about the syntax and
semantics i want to give kind of give
for this side of the room it seems like
this side of the room knows lt i've
heard about ltl but this size of room a
little bit less i don't know if this is
kind of uh
there's anything going on here i'm not
going to interrogate that
roughly speaking so propositional logic
you've all seen it whether you know it
was called propositional logic or not
that's a different question but you know
you have propositions hadas in stanford
true
you know hadas in ithaca false
and so on
that's propositional logic and or not
you can create more complex statements
and evaluate their truth value is it
true you know hadas
at stanford and hadas in ithaca that's
false and so on
now if you add a notion of time can you
add the fact that propositions can
change with time now you can write
specifications you can write formulas
logical formulas that have um kind of a
more expressive power in terms of time
right you can say
eventually hadas and ithaca yes you know
my family's there because i want to go
see them
uh always had that's an ethica no here's
a here's a counter example right so i'm
right now i'm not in ithaca
it's a new york obviously by the way if
people have not heard about it uh where
cornell is um and so on so i can start
writing things um uh that are more
complex in terms of
uh temple operators in terms of
conditions i can put implications you
know
if it's
friday april
29th 29th if it's that friday april 29th
friday april 29th implies that ithaca
that formula is true and so on
i guess they should have had eventually
there
yes sigma i'm guessing is state and i is
good
somewhere
time
uh so excellent question so uh yes so
ltl formulas are
evaluated over infinite sequences of
truth values for the propositions
sigma is uh that infinite sequence of
states and i is that position of the
state so ltl doesn't have explicit time
it has steps notions of steps
uh the the next logic we'll talk about
has uh so this goes back to to um versus
question about uh time about
abstractions right for ltl my
abstraction is
things there's some sequence but i don't
have explicit time in there so i can't
say things like
within five minutes
i'll be at whatever wherever we're
having lunch right there's i can't
express that i
kind of can by abstracting it and having
maybe a timer that can increment by one
but that's really clunky and really not
the best way of this so if i want to
write ltl specifications i'm getting rid
of the notion of explicit time i'm going
to say eventually now that eventually
could be you know in five seconds could
be in five years
right so so the question is do i care
about that if i do care about that if
that's part of the properties i care
about which is time this is not the
logic to use
excellent question
but if i don't if i care about
composition so a lot of the times um the
way you want to think about using these
kinds of specific
of specifications it's a really hard
word to say fast i have to say
so every time you think about
specifications when you think about ltl
and when you think about stl which we'll
talk about in a second
there's the notion of comp of
composition really the idea here is we
have these propositions we have these
pies
in ithaca
at stanford and those when we talk about
robotics which are physical systems
continuous behaviors and so on there's a
mapping between those propositions
and the and the physical world
so in my work we typically attach these
propositions to either
uh events in the environment so sensing
so perception actually perception is
probably the better word
um abstracted perception or we attach it
to controllers
so or or or to or change in propositions
to be more more precise we
we attach changes in propositions to
controllers
to low-level controllers
so what can we do with ltl i want to
show you uh
two examples of different projects we've
had
where we had the underlying
formalism that we used to create the
high-level behaviors was linear temporal
logic
and i'm not in this talk i'm not talking
at all about
given an ltl formula how do i generate
the controller the synthesis process not
going to be talking about that um if you
want chat after lecture happy to but uh
for now i just want to show you the kind
of expressive power and how we think
about what these propositions are and
how what kind of specifications we can
put what kind of information we can
extract back from that
so here's s'mores
s'mores are uh you can see up there
um these are modular robots the hardware
this was a joint project with markie
emma penn uh mark campbell at cornell
who does more of the pers so mercum does
uh modular robots hardware
mark mark campbell we had two marks out
of three pis it's very it's very uh
it causes more problems than you think
um
mike campbell cornell more on the
percentage inside and myself more on the
high level specifications and and uh
behaviors
these are uh these are modular robots
have anybody see has anybody seen these
before
well you better
so it was it was definitely when you
were
i guess you overlapped with this with
tariq right um
so these uh these are 10 centimeter cube
modules they have uh four degrees of
freedom they have two wheels
they have a pen on the top and then they
tilt you can kind of they can bend in
the middle
the interesting thing about them as you
can see on the side there are these half
moons
those are electro permanent electro
permanent magnets they can be turned on
and off
with a very very very high very very
very short current so in terms of power
top too bad
um so what this allows us it allows us
to create structures
modular robots so different
configurations different connectivity of
these modules and different gates
different behaviors for each um
okay so let me run this again so you can
see what's going on there so this is
times four just
so it has one gate in which it's
lowering itself it's moving
it has a it has a gate that kind of
pushes back up so it's lifting up this
box
and then the way the modules are set up
it kind of becomes a
hanomic robot so it can turn place so
you can move in any direction
using this kind of configuration
so this allows us to not only
create different shapes it allows us to
reconfigure autonomously
so we can change shapes as the robot is
executing
and the question that we had for that
project this was an nsf uh project um
sfcps project that's
a few years
um the deal is how do we do high-level
behaviors for these modular robots
because now the design space is not just
where the controller is but what are the
shapes of these robots
so the way we thought about that
was we had the top there is is um
uh remember those propositions we have
to ground these propositions into
something physical
so the way we grounded the positions
here we had sensors and those sensors
were
abstracted by from the perception system
so we can detect stairs for example the
the you'll see i'll show you the video
in a second uh we had um
an lgbt camera
uh pointing at the environment to do
kind of uh to characterize what the
environment looks like so we could
detect stairs we could detect cliffs and
so on and then we had a camera pointing
down for uh reconfiguration
so the sensors were it was using that
rgb camera
we had the propositions
were actually properties of the
different configurations and gates so
created a library of configurations and
gates and each one of these
configurations and gates had different
properties so for example there's a
property of climb stairs so there are
certain configurations certain shapes
the robot can take and certain gates the
the um patterns of actuation
of the different motors create different
behaviors for the full robot and some of
them can climb upstairs some of them
cannot
so the propositions that we use here the
propositions for the high level behavior
were these properties of these
configurations and gates so we have this
library
um
i don't remember exactly the number now
but you know
i don't remember the number now but
definitely on the order of 50
configuration gates something like that
then we can write specifications this is
ltl for example always
if you see stairs which is this which
was
an input from the perception system
then you should be in a configuration
that can climb
and then we had a mapping between the
different configuration gates to the
property climb
so now it could be one of different you
know n different configuration gates yes
so
it seems from this slide let's try to
come off that
you are tying the ltl specification to
um whatever abstraction over the sensors
you're getting
all right so if i have like a stair
classifier that's outputting i don't
know 52 percent actors
uh
what i'm saying is there exactly
something else
um
your the specification is just going to
assume that the stair and everything's
great
are there
ltl like formalisms that like
accommodate for the probabilities and
the likelihoods that we're getting from
the underlying perception systems yes
yes so uh two things in terms of that so
uh just i wanna just
make a slightly more precise statement
from what you said i'm not tying the ltl
i'm trying tying the propositions so the
propositions have some physical meaning
and you're absolutely right that in this
formalism
either stairs or not stairs if you have
a classifier with some probability
distribution i don't care you tell me
stairs are not stairs right and i would
argue to some extent robotics is a lot
like that at some point you have to make
a decision that decision has to be made
on you know
is there answer or not okay but it is
more nuanced than that for sure
so there are probabilistic logics there
is work on synthesizing using mdps so
market decision mark of decision
processes where you think about kind of
uh and you can you can think about
different optimization criteria around
that um
there's also work on verification so we
have a paper that's going to be
presented next week at hscc um on
uh public probabilistic verification of
sdl uh specification given sensor models
sorry given sensor noise
and then you can start thinking you can
so there are kind of two ways to do this
you can either say okay i'm just gonna
someone's gonna tell me and i'm gonna
assume it's the truth here let me
synthesize the behavior that is
guaranteed to be correct
with respect to the fact that i actually
got correct information from the
environment
then what you can do you can um
add the probabilities and do probably
probabilistic verification on the
synthesized system and we've done this
in the past in the context of kind of a
self-driving car so a few years ago uh
um we had this kind of navigating an
intersection and what happens if and you
have a projection of another vehicle and
then what happens you know um
do
basically see how different behave
different
specifications on the kind of absolute
system
what are the likelihood of collisions
given that you have sensory noise so
yeah so that's kind of uh um
they're both they're both techniques
right but at some point you're gonna
make a decision right so that's kind of
the thing you know and you don't and
going back to the safety versus liveness
i mean i can always make a decision not
to move right don't quite don't don't
quite want to do that yeah
all right and then we saw we have uh
kind of always if you see pink you pick
up an object and the video you're going
to see in a second uh it's actually drop
it object and i just noticed it this
morning i didn't want to mess with my
slides so uh it's gonna match
so in this specific case what we're
doing we're taking linear temporal logic
and the complexity of taking the full
ltl and generating a controller from
that or generating a state machine that
satisfies that
uh is not good it's double exponential
in the size of the formula
uh there is a subset of ltl it's called
gr1 that has better computational
properties so again not
super scalable i mean if if if there's
one criticism i've gotten
pretty much on everything i've submitted
ever
how does it scale not particularly well
but you know working on it
the gr1 kind of a fragment this is when
when i say reactive synthesis for ltl
typically that's the people typically
think about the j1
um
fragment
so what we do we take this formula and
we generate a stick machine that
satisfies such that every execution of
the state machine satisfies the original
formula
and then what we do is we look at those
transitions
and each transition the state machine
corresponds to in this case a
configuration gate
so actually no i i i misspoke what the
transitions here correspond to the
different properties we need on the
configurations and gates
so what this allows me to do
is as i'm synthesizing
i can figure out whether i'm missing
some behaviors that might show up
for example
if i see stairs and pink at the same
time
i need a configuration and can both
climb and pick up an object
what if i don't have that but if there
does not exist a configuration gate in
my library
that um that has that combination
so i can know ahead of time before
executing before trying to run uh now
it could be the case that i never see
stairs it could be the case that i never
see a pink object that's totally fine
i'm not assuming anything about the
environment in terms of whether events
occur
i'm just saying if it happens this is
how i want to react
so we can find ahead of time
possible failures
that could happen during execution
based on events i have no control over
which is the environmental event
that's kind of what we do so we can and
there this is kind of a
um
an ongoing motif and kind of the work
that my group does and other groups kind
of that work within the space do as well
the idea that you can use those
specifications to tell ahead of time
what can go wrong you can tell as you're
going what can go wrong using runtime
martyring or anti-verification
uh and you'll see i'll show you an
example of that in in a bit
okay so um
that's the specification that is not how
you yes yes oh yeah yeah it's very
interesting so uh whether you couldn't
predict all possible failure cases
what do you mean by that
so you mentioned like if you want to you
know specify all the possible failure
cases right before the execution of the
robot what if you couldn't cover all the
possible failures
yeah
awesome so you bring me to a really
wonderful point so i don't know if
everybody heard the question
if i cannot
um what happens if i can't predict all
failure cases so i'm actually not
predicting any failure cases what i'm
trying to to figure out is is there a
possibility for me to not be able to
satisfy my specification
so if there's anything that could go
wrong in my specification then i'll be
able to tell you that now huge huge
asterisks on that
this is only with respect to the
abstraction i have what are the pieces
that i have
and with respect to my specification
so for example you know
batteries dying
is not part of my specification not part
of my abstraction
if all the batteries die
i can't tell you that right
more specifically in this example we had
a bunch of uh
failed demonstrations
because the wi-fi stopped working right
or there was an issue with the wi-fi
whatever but i don't know purchase was
weird in that way right um
the wi-fi didn't work and these are
controlled
uh
i mean a lot these were control kind of
offline with fully autonomous but there
were there was a requirement of wi-fi
and that so those kinds of failures i
can't
predict i can't detect i can't because
it's it's not sitting in my abstraction
which comes again to the to
the door's point in the beginning was
where where does that abstraction lie
right so if i if i'm uh if there's no
words for it in my language right if i'm
not you know
modules failing it's not part of my
language i won't be able to detect those
kinds of failures
so this is always this is kind of the
the i guess i guess now i have two two
things i want you to take out of this
lecture one
specifications
two
there's no such thing as always works
ever
it's always with respect to something
in this case it would be worth with
respect to my configurations and gates
with respect to my abstracted events if
my stair um detector is like 51 percent
accurate and my cutoff is 50 and there
are no stairs there i'm gonna fail
so there's about being able to to figure
out
what guarantees you can provide safety
under what
envelope that is super important super
important also in the context of uh
um not over selling right what can i say
when can i say it and this is true in
general for safety for anything when
actually for any engineering system
don't over sell
okay so uh
look for a pink object if you find one
go there and drop off the object
so there's no grasping here whatsoever
these are magnets we have a magnet
attached to it so we can we can turn on
and off these magnets i can drop things
by turning off a magnet
and that is by no means the way we
interact with the robot that is our
interpretation of an ltl formula that is
fairly long
not horribly complicated but not as
natural to write as that so with those
those two things
but what i do want to show you i want to
show you two videos same exact
specification same exact uh
configuration gate
library
and you're going to see two different
behaviors because the environment is
different
say again same everything different
behaviors because the environment is
different and that's kind of another uh
advantage of the specification because i
wrote something that's more general
that's more abstract it didn't say okay
when you reach the stairs now dump
you'll see in a second
and this is time eight times eight
so these are pretty slow
so on the left what you'll see is that
it cannot climb stairs that way so it's
just gonna dump two modules or actually
four modules oh no two two
here it can't reach up high
so it's going to reconfigure itself into
this kind of proboscis uh configuration
you can see on the right
this is fully autonomous you can see the
um the magnets are very sensitive to
misalignment so we have these qr tags on
top for so and does like this little bit
of a dance to create this
so dump something and then it's just
going to continue exploring but it can't
turn
using the the snake configuration just
can't turn anywhere so you have to add
those robe those uh blocks again
and and so on
yeah
so the specification here was high level
enough to capture very different
behaviors
even though um well that's i guess
that's what i was trying to say
we also did this kind of more um
okay this is the baxter so baxter is
something that definitely you know you
buy or used to be able to buy i guess
not no longer
um and this is kind of this is work with
um
uh tom howard up in in the university of
rochester
up for me
so
upstate new york
um
here's the test so this kind of uh work
looking at how can we use natural
language to do these kinds of uh
do the mapping from natural language to
the robot control
with the intermediate representation
being in this case linear temporal logic
so learning the grounding of the
different words to physical things
learning the grounding of sentences into
ltl formulas and being able to to do
that okay
so pick up the blue block and drop in
the box on your right
uh imagine the robot this is the right
um pick up the red block drop it in the
box on your left this is what you'll see
so one thing i want to show you here so
this is the actual input this was
natural language
input to the system it's pretty slow so
i can talk over this so it's picking up
the blue block
slowly i really should speed this up
and then what do you expect
what do you expect to do is it ding what
you're expecting it to do
not really right it's just hanging onto
that blue block
picking up the red block
thinking
it's going to put the red block and i
promise you it's also going to put the
blue block
okay so is this correct behavior
yes no is it doing with the
specification good yeah according to the
specification all the rules are
satisfied yeah this is correct behavior
when you're watching it especially at
the speed
what is your thought process
say what just drop the blue gloss just
drop the blue block oh my gosh why are
you holding on to it right so it's doing
something that is correct
but if you're looking at this especially
the speed
and you're just like
is it actually gonna do what i'm
expecting it to do is it so this notion
of perceived safety is something that
will come up
um well it won't come up but this is
something that
it is correct it is safe
not probably the best and there's a
there's an explanation of why it's doing
it this way but uh um but you know
there's the notion of safety becomes a
little more tricky here
so when i read that blurb um i had some
i thought it had some implications that
you want to drop the
um blue block before you pick up the red
block um and so i guess
the broader question would be like it
seems hard to encode logic in english
um yeah yeah yeah 100 100 agree with you
so it's it's not that it's hard to
encode logic in english but english is
more ambiguous than the logic
so the logic i mean
i'm with you when i look at that blurb
i'm kind of well i'm kind of expecting
you pick it up you drop it pick it up
and drop it why why would you hang on to
things doesn't it doesn't make any sense
right it's not optimal whatever optimal
means here
but this english actually doesn't say
that
right so it just says those are these
are the actions that you need to do
and we could create a behavior that will
pick it up drop it pick it up drop it it
kind of depends on the ordering inside
the logic formula but there but the fact
that the uh language is more ambiguous
than the logic that you write
causes this interesting mismatch right
yeah so um two questions
first
if i put a then pick up
in front of the second sentence would it
actually do the right thing
what we think the right thing should be
depending on how you map it to the ltl
but if if your question is can i write
that in ltl yes absolutely yeah yeah
yeah and the second question is
do you label business a problem though
well actually actually sorry let me back
up
then is still ambiguous
yes because it doesn't say immediately
after
right
if you say it implies after it
kind of right so if i say pick up the
blue block and before you do anything
else drop it
that's an ambiguous and then we can
definitely we can capture that
in the logic for sure but then i mean
i'm with you on the fact that it's
implies to me more immediacy but i don't
know if that's
kind of
right the language is language is hard
so i you know worked with a few
computational linguists actually with
chris potts who who
was at
stanford um oh my gosh language even the
pragmatics oh my gosh
yeah inside the second question
i guess the second question is you label
this as a problem of perceived safety um
is it just belief mismatch
between the human and the robot and
are you like this is correct under the
robots of the world oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah human like
effectively nothing has really changed
so if i made the effort to educate the
human as an hri problem like this what
robot is going to do when you say
something like this
and if you wanted this behavior this is
what you should have said
um that doesn't feel as much of a safety
problem as much as like a
language yeah yeah yeah so so maybe
perceived safety is probably not the
right term to use here but it's there's
a mismatch mismatch of expectations
that is interesting because it's not
clear from the actual language where
that's coming from so one of the things
that i'll get to that in a second but
but one of the things that that
i find super exciting these days and and
i have you know some wonderful
collaborators in the hr space um is
how do you bridge that
what do you do with that mismatch with
that mismatch of
it's safe it's correct but it's not
quite what i wanted right what do we do
with that so and there's a bunch of kind
of things we can
that doesn't match human expectations
exactly like see safety problems like it
doesn't necessarily
mean it's only a perceived safety
problem like it could do things that are
bad because by specifications we didn't
encode the set of all
bad things
so i'm not talking but even by bad so
this would you consider this behavior
bad i mean no but it's employed behavior
sure like to talk about like safe and
unsafe systems i i don't think it's good
to make safe a synonym for correct
we're like correct by our specification
because our our specification could
result in unsafe behavior
that's correct that's 100 agree with
that 100 so there's a mismatch between
what you want your system to do and what
you tell it to do so that's a mismatch
that i don't quite know how to deal with
with the one exception of providing
examples counter examples explanations
so there are techniques using these kind
of of logics these kinds of or
more broadly specifications
specifications you can generate from
to allow you to kind of bridge that
mismatch a little bit but but but
there's not a really good
anyway yeah so that would be like
generating examples from the
specifications so like you could say
okay generate 100 examples of what what
the robot could do and then one of them
is like okay pick up the blue block pick
up the red
and then you're like oh that's not what
i intended
and then fixed from that it's maybe not
perfect but it's at least better than
that yeah yeah so i will say when you do
synthesis you get a deterministic system
so you can show one example but the fact
that you have i think
the um
the value
of having specifications is or uh kind
of formal specification of formal very
broadly construed but
let's say computable specifications is
now you can ideally create systems from
them
show examples of the system for them
you know uh um
figure out when things are not happening
according to the specifications of this
kind of monitoring because something
else because my batteries failed
whatever
right and and use that to create the and
there's a there's a bunch of work now on
providing feedback using these kind of
counter examples and all these things
and and to refine specifications there's
a bunch of work on uh learning
specifications from human demonstrations
so we you learn uh you learn an abstract
formula and then you give an example and
then the person's like well i'm not sure
about that it kind of refines so there's
a bunch of really cool work in that
space as well um and then but but i
think but ultimate underlying is my i
think my fundamental point of
specifications you should think about
specifications you should be writing
specific you know and so on
so what can we do with this in case in
this case with specifications
um
i'm just checking the time
okay let me go quickly through this
uh
there are some time so something
something that definitely shows up when
people write specifications
is that they um
they don't necessarily give you complete
specifications
there might be cases in which you know
you give parts to specification because
everything else you either assume is is
there or you didn't think about possible
failure modes and so on for example pick
up the blue block and place it in the
right bin you're assuming there's a blue
block there right
is there a blue block
will there be a blue block will it stay
there enough for me to pick it up so on
so those are kinds of things that you
can capture
and again this is arguable
what you want to
automate
versus what you want to ask the user
versus what you want to figure out right
the
as kind of you're going through it but
for example what we can do in this
specific work what we did was we could
write a specification from those
instructions
figure out that we're missing something
make it missing an assumption then go
back and ask will the blue block remain
within reach
for example and if the answer is yes
great i'm going to continue if the
answer is no well you know can't do it
right so that's kind of the things we
can do
with these kinds of things
right um
single temporal logic
so i am
let me go quickly through this
uh we talked about time right ltl does
not have a good notion of time i would
argue you don't always have to have a
good notion of time to do different
behaviors right for for the modular
robots i didn't really care about the
timing for the picking of the blocks i
didn't care about the timing
if i do care about the timing lt is not
ltl is not the right logic and there's
um scl's be coming to single temporal
logic there's also metric temporal logic
and metric interval temporal logic
there's a bunch of
other things like that
that
do allow you to capture continuous
properties
and the main difference again this is uh
totally hand wavy so you know bear with
me with the whole hand wavy thing here
but the uh the only one thing about the
difference between signal temporal logic
and and linear temporal logic so sdl and
ltl is now my propositions are actually
predicates they're functions over
continuous signals
so i can think about distance
i can think about you know just whatever
whatever
continuous
function you want
and i have this notion of time
so we have eventually between a and b
always between a and b
phi 1 has to be true until
v2 is true and p2 has to be true between
a and b
and a and b are time
times now again this is typically done i
mean
it's kind of over continuous systems
it's really over discrete time
continuous systems
it's a lot of time synthesized using
either model predictive control so you
kind of print you know um with a finite
horizon
or more recently
using control barrier functions for a
subset of stl
and so on
we've been looking at this so we've been
playing around with this
what we've we've came up with recently
to be able to capture kind of the
this doesn't have necessarily a good way
to capture
uh discrete events
so stairs not stairs are there not there
right this doesn't really fit within
that you could kind of fit within that
not quite
so the notion of reaction to external
events
you can capture this here with the
notion of
continuous signal so if i want to
maintain a distance from an uncontrolled
if i want a robot to maintain a distance
from a human
i can write that there because i can
look at the person's
um continuous location robots can use
location write a predicate over that
but like an alarm
turning on and off doesn't really fit
here
so we've kind of created the
event-based sdl so this is kind of
using
control barrier functions which is
computationally pretty efficient and
being able to
add
events
we're able to capture kind of different
different behaviors there so
the main thing i want to show you there
the main thing i want to show you there
is
we can automatically synthesize controls
we cannot guarantee
we will always be correct because there
might be uncontrollable events
so if i want to maintain distance from
from a person
and that person just runs away cannot
guarantee that
right
but what we can do with this kind of
logic is tell you i'm about to violate
the specification
or i think i'm going to violate the
specification or if this happens now
i can't do it sorry
so let me show you kind of a quick
example of that there's there's there's
uh
five autonomous robots here one robot
that's controlled by david who's my
student uh he's controlling this green
robot
he's just still operating it these are
vectors you know the anki vectors uh
super cute
and
it doesn't really matter what's going on
the top but the bottom what's happening
is that that
black robot is typically on this side
and whenever it detects that there's
something and there's a robot in that or
an uncontrolled robot in that
rectangle it needs to come it needs to
get there within 25 seconds and then it
needs to lead the other robot
uh to the edge of this hallway within 60
seconds
and it has to maintain a distance from
the green robot
okay so you can tell that if the green
robot doesn't refuse us to move then
you know can't can't do this
so here's kind of what's going on there
so you can see the pre-failure mornings
so the the black robot is always at the
edge of almost violating um
the green robot is not so it's not
moving so much or now it's moving so
it's close it stopped
the black one had to to kind of reduce
its speed
stopping again had to reduce the speed
and you guys need to get within 60
seconds back to that uh to the edge
and now what you'll see in a second is
that if another robot shows up now
the leading robot cannot go back and get
the other one as well
so this is kind of telling you
i need form
if another robot shows up i need four
more seconds to be able to lead that one
also
yes
being generated or no what do you mean
by the trumpet again
like do i like can i know for sure that
like like can i formally verify that the
pre-failure warning is always going to
occur before failure
given like some
abstract like given some assumptions
so um
the pre-failure warnings will always be
given
they're under the assumption that the
robot can move it at its max speed
and it's with respect to the
specification that that uh that's uh
that's written right um
[Music]
yeah what i cannot guarantee i cannot
guarantee that i might i might not have
a solution sometimes if i have
conflicting things if for example i need
to maintain distance from the green
robot and it's just charging at me i
won't be able to find a solution for
that
right so there there are things i won't
be able to guarantee here especially the
ones that have to do with the behavior
of the uncontrolled event
i can if i put assumptions on it then i
can i can kind of refine that but we're
not really putting out any assumptions
about the behavior of the other robot of
that sorry the behavior of the
uncontrolled
entity in this
i'm case if you can formalize this in
some way where you run into the halting
problem
why
i'm not sure i haven't thought it
through
um
i don't think so because the
specifications are i mean you have all
the parameters of the robot you know how
fast it's going to move you know all the
timing constraints you know the the
worst case scenarios of the of the other
robots so you really have all the
information it's a matter of solving an
optimization problem right so and you
can put kind of bounce around that so i
don't think so
could be wrong but i don't think so
okay so i'm going to skip this what i
want to show you is that using this kind
of event-based stl
we're uh currently we have an nri
project uh guy hoffman kirsten peterson
and myself and what we're doing there is
we're looking at um different
interactions for robots and kind of a
in this case a building evacuation
scenario
and what we did we did this is this is
user study iteration too because you
know pilot
user study
not quite
useful information well that's not
difficult very useful information
unpublishable user user user study too
uh which is going on is being wrapped up
right now
and we wanted to examine different types
of behaviors
so there's gonna be the robot on the
left okay so what is that what is the
objective objective is get out of the
building
um we want to make people less compliant
by having them pick up things along the
way
so they get uh
money they get money for anything they
they uh pick up as long as they get out
of the
of this environment within whatever five
minutes or three minutes or whatever
so we have two different behaviors the
only difference this is kind of again
going back i'm gonna keep
saying specifications the only
difference in creating those two
behaviors
was rewriting these two sent these two
ltl formulas sorry stl formulas event
based stale formulas into these two
so a few character changes and we get a
totally different behavior that's kind
of the power of specifications
and what you'll see here
i can't watch it because i get motion
sickness so uh the one on the left if
you get watching sixes don't watch the
one on the left uh it's passive so it's
gonna follow the robot and follow the
person until the person says okay lead
me to the exit
the one on the right is an active
behavior where the robot gets the the
person's attention and then just just
goes
and every time it doesn't have line of
sight it will come back kind of peek at
you
and keep going
and we're we're seeing so we also i mean
user study number one was we also tried
to find a difference between active and
passive was not distinct didn't get any
useful information didn't get any uh
interesting uh behaviors there
but now we're starting to get kind of
interested people are
i don't have
it's not fully analyzed yet but there's
some interesting behaviors in terms of
passive versus active but in terms of
the specification the fact that we wrote
this
and we got the autonomous behavior of
the robot
um from those specifications made it
super easy to change the parameters of
the user study
or
i should never use the word super easy
with the word user study at the same
sentence but you get what i'm saying
right so it was the changing
the simulation was was easy
which brings me to kind of the final
thing i want to talk about and i'm oh
i'm over time so let me i'll stop in
with this slide this is the second paper
that they put there and this is um
professor sadie is also on on this uh on
this paper this came out of a um
a workshop we had
28 19 2019. i keep forgetting it was
2019 2019
um about formalizing and guaranteeing
human orbit interaction
and i'm just going to leave you with
what should formal specifications look
like for hri
should be ltl probably not
should be stl
maybe closer to that
what should the propositions be what
should the predicates be
where do i kind of put in things like
probabilities like rewards like there's
a bunch of really interesting questions
there which is a which is a
topic that i would if you have any
interest in thinking about this talking
about this i am
would be delighted to because i think
this is a
very
new open field to kind of
look at what are the specifications for
these kinds of systems when we care
about
not so much
safety as in don't kill me
but interaction what makes for a good
interaction
and there's a lot of there's work in the
community that's starting to address
that but i would say that i don't know
if you agree with that but we don't know
how to do that yet and and that's that's
exciting because that's where research
goes
okay let me stop here i'm over time
thank you very much and happy to take
any questions